hi in this module i'm going to present
the formal definition of bayesian
networks give a few examples and then
talk about a really interesting property
called explaining away
so before we begin i want to review some
basic probability
so suppose we have some random variables
we have one called s which is
representing whether they're sunshine
and another random variable called r
which represents whether there's rain
so you should think about a setting
of values to s and r as capturing some
state of the world
so we don't know which state of the
world we're in so we're going to capture
this uncertainty using a joint
distribution
so the joint distribution over s and r
in p s comma r is equal to
a table
and this table specifies for every
possible assignment to snr
i'm going to have a probability
associated with it so for example
there's the probability of no sun and no
rain is 0.2
snow sun and rain is 0.08 and so on and
so forth
so notice that i'm using lowercase
letters to denote values and uppercase
letters to denote the random variables
and also notice that
this quantity is a number it's a
probability whereas this quantity
is a table
so the joint distribution captures
everything that you really want to know
you can think about it as a
probabilistic database
that
captures how the world works
so now we can use the joint distribution
to answer all sorts of interesting
questions
so we can compute what is called a
marginal distribution so the idea here
is that suppose i'm interested in only
whether it's sunshine or not i don't
care about whether it's raining
so we can compute p of s
and this is a table
which specifies the possible values of s
0 1 and the probability the marginal
probability of that particular value
so how do we compute this we simply
aggregate rows
so in particular we're going to look at
s equals 0
look at the joint distribution and match
all the rows where s is zero so these
two and add them up so that gives us
0.28
and then for s equals one the matching
rows are these last two rows and that
gives us 0.72 that's the marginal
distribution over s
so there's also another concept called
conditional distribution
and here the idea is that suppose
i knew it was raining so i'm going to
condition on r equals one
so now i want to know what is the
probability of sunshine
so this is a table where i again specify
the possible values of s zero one and i
want to know the probability the
conditional probability of s given r
equals one
so the way i want to approach
conditional distribution is as follows i
have this condition r equals one
that means i'm going to effectively
remove
all the rows where r does not equal one
i'm left with these two
and now i'm going to
um
simply normalize this distribution so i
have zero point zero eight and 0.02 the
sum is 0.1 so i divide by that sum
and that's going to give me 0.8 and 0.2
for
the values of
s given r equals 1.
so
all we did was select the rows that
match the condition
and normalize to get
the
distribution
and now just a simple note is that
the normalization constant which is the
sum of these two
is actually the probability of r equals
the marginal probability of r equals one
you can check that the conditional by
definition is equal to the joint divided
by the marginal of the thinking
so let's expand our example a little bit
so suppose we have variables now
sunshine rain
traffic
and autumn
so we have a joint distribution over all
four variables
and we can
marginal and conditioning are not
mutually exclusive we can actually
define core
questions that involve both so here is
an example suppose i
know that it's uh there's traffic and
that we're in the autumn quarter
and now we're interested in a particular
variable query variable
in this case r
so this question can be written as
follows the probability
of the query variable r condition on
this evidence t equals one a equals one
okay so now
the variables which are not mentioned
here are said to be marginalized out so
s is not mentioned here so we're
marginalizing out s
okay so in general there's three
sets of variables the query variables
the conditioning variables and
the marginalized out variables which
form a partition of all the variables in
your
in your system
so now let's turn to a classic puzzle
which we will solve using
suppose that in the world
there are unfortunate things such as
earthquakes and burglaries and suppose
that they're independent events and
hopefully rare um each of them happens
with probability epsilon probably
epsilon is some small
um you've installed an alarm which will
go off whenever
either there's an earthquake or
um
there's a burglar so you got some
special deal where it's like a
two-in-one kind of alarm
so um suppose you're away on vacation
and then you got a notification that
your alarm went off okay
so now
um
does hearing that there's an earthquake
on
uh the radio or on your news feed
increase decrease or keep constant the
probability of burglar
okay so if does knowing that there's an
earthquake in addition to alarm how does
that change your beliefs about a
burglary
so
now we could try to intuit the answer
and i would encourage you to do that and
see if you're right but
sometimes this is uh can be very
slippery because the right answer could
be counterintuitive
so you might think that because well
earthquakes and burglaries i said
they're independent
so knowing that there's an earthquake
why should that change the probability
of berkeley that's one way to think
about it but that turns out to be wrong
and i'll show you why
so let's try to tackle this problem
using bayesian networks
so we're going to define a joint
distribution over
earthquake burglary and alarm i'll do
this in the next slide but first let's
talk about the questions let's convert
this word problem into mathematical
notation here
so the two things i want to compare is
what is the probability of there being a
burglary given only that i heard an
alarm
versus what is the probability of a
burglary given that i heard an alarm and
i heard that there's an earthquake
so is it smaller is it the same is it
larger and that's what i want to know
so now let us define the bayesian
network of
completely
so there's going to be four steps um to
thinking about how to define a bayesian
network
first of all let's uh figure out what
the variables are so the variables are
whether there's a burglary b whether
there's an earthquake e and whether
there's uh the alarm went off or on a
okay
second what we're going to do is to
model the dependencies between
these variables using directed arrows
and these capture
you can think about them as capturing
causality but although that's
not necessarily the case here
and so these are meant to just capture
qualitative relationships so here the
alarm is triggered off either by the
burglary or an earthquake so that seems
sensible
so to make this qualitative relationship
it's quantitative i'm going to define
a local conditional distribution for
each variable conditioned on its parents
so let's go through these examples so we
have b that's a variable
so a local conditional distribution
specifies
for each possible value of b
what is this probability so
i said that the probability of burglary
is epsilon and that means the
probability of no burglary is one minus
sub-small
um then we look at e
e has no parents as well so um the
probability of uh earthquake is
epsilon and the probability of no
earthquake is one minus
so now let's turn into the um and i can
write these conditional distributions as
follows as well so i can write
probability of b
is epsilon times indicator of b equals 1
plus 1 minus epsilon times indicator b
0. so if i plug in 1 here then i'm going
to get epsilon and if i plug in 0
i'm going to get 1 minus epsilon and
same with probability of epsilon e
so now the what is the probability of a
given its parents
so
it's easiest to write it actually
mathematically like this
so this is just the indicator of whether
a equals b or e
so this is a deterministic relationship
but i've lifted this to this
probabilistic notation
i can also
write this out as a table where i
specify
for every possible configuration of the
parents
and of a itself
what is its probability
so here if a b
and e are zero
command
and does a equal
uh is zero equal a zero or zero
that's yes so this probability is one
zero or a zero equal one the answer is
no so that's a zero because uh zero or z
one equal zero
that's also a no
and the zero or one equal one
um the answer is yes so that's a one
go on the rest of the table analogously
okay so now i have defined a local
conditional distribution for each
variable
given its parents
and now
the final step is to multiply all these
together and that is defined
as the joint distribution over all the
random variable
so notice that i'm deliberately using
two types of p here so one is lowercase
p which is used to specify
the local conditional disk probabilities
and the blackboard uppercase p is
reserved for the joint distribution and
also derived marginal and conditional
distributions
so notice that again that these local
conditional distributions are just
defined
whereas this joint distribution is
derived from the local conditional
distribution
all right so the joint distribution like
i said is the simply the product of all
the local conditional distributions so
if i work that out i get this table over
all possible assignments to be ena and
its probability
okay so now i can work on
these questions that i'm asking so this
is my probabilistic database let's go
query it
so let's warm up with something
relatively simple so probability what is
the marginal probability of b
equals one here
okay so remember how do i compute
marginal probability i look at b equals
one okay so that selects these rows down
here and i simply add up these
probabilities so there's epsilon times 1
minus epsilon
and then adding
epsilon squared
so that gives me epsilon minus epsilon
squared plus epsilon squared equals
epsilon
okay so what about
probability of burglary
condition on the alarm
so remember for conditional
distributions
i'm going to now wipe out all the rows
where a
is not one
um
this
so i'm left with all these rows which
are consistent with my evidence of equal
one
and now
i'm going to look at
um probability of b equals one so that
is are these two rows
and now i add
um epsilon 1 minus epsilon
plus
um
epsilon squared
okay and i'm going to divide by the sum
of all these three things which is
same as the numerator plus this
additional one minus epsilon times
epsilon
if you do the math here you get uh one
over two minus epsilon
okay so this intuitively makes sense um
the prior probability of a burglary is
small but if i hear alarm then this goes
up to actually a little bit over 50
percent
so now the final
question is what is the probability of
burglary given that i heard the alarm
and also i hear that there's an
earthquake
okay so i'm conditioning on now a equals
one and equals one so i'm going to wipe
out
the rows where
e is zero
and now i am left with what's the
probability of equals one so that is
epsilon squared
divided by
the sum over these two probabilities
which is epsilon squared plus one minus
f squared epsilon and this gives me
if you do the math it gives me epsilon
okay so this answers our question now
um when i
heard the alarm the probability
of a burglary uh goes up rightfully but
now
i see that if there is an earthquake or
hear that there's an earthquake that
probably goes down back to epsilon
okay so the answer to the question is
that
observing the earthquake does cause the
problem of burglary to go down
okay so let me actually work
convince you of this via this demo so
here um remember from this
before that we can define arbitrary
factor graphs including major networks
using this tool so we have three
variables uh b e and a
epsilon we're setting to 0.05 here
um i'm going to define factors or local
conditional distributions here
probability of
a b
probability of e probability of a given
b and e
and
now i'm going to ask for the probability
of b
um so
if i step through this algorithm i see
that the probability of b is
0.05 which is epsilon
so now what happens when i condition on
a
when i condition on a
i find that the probability of b
condition on equals 1 is
0.51 so remember this is 1 over 2
minus epsilon
so now
um
finally i'm going to condition on
earthquake um
here
if i condition an earthquake then
i see that the probability of burglary
goes down to 0.05 which is epsilon
okay so
what do i learn what have we learned
from this so you can write a flashy
headline saying earthquakes decrease
burglaries
okay so
of course this is run a little bit time
and cheat because this is actually not a
causal statement you have to be because
if you go in and cause some earthquakes
i don't know how you would do that but
supposing you do
then it's not like all the buller goes
are going to
disappear so um here decrease does not
mean you know causal effect it just
means that
given this evidence then actually the
probability of of various other
variables change
so the punch line here is that
you know dealing with all these
probabilities and
reasoning under certainty is quite
slippery
so
we need some sort of sound mathematical
framework such as bayesian networks to
deliver um the right answers
so this type of
phenomenon is
is so important to bayesian networks
that it has a special name it's called
explaining away
so in general explaining away is when
you have two causes
or more that have positively influenced
an effect
so condition on effect
further conditioning on one cause it
actually reduces the probability of the
other cause
so mathematically this is written as
probability of
uh the other cause given
the effect and
one of the causes is less than the
probability of the cause given just the
effect alone
and this is true even if the causes are
independent which is might be somewhat
of the counter to it counterintuitive
effect and this is kind of the hallmark
of bayesian networks this is called a v
structure it looks like a v
um so you can rationalize this uh if you
want some intuition as follows so
you have this effect
and you observe a equals one and now
you're trying to seek an explanation for
what caused
this effect it's a b or e
so just
condition on a
well it could be either one so it's kind
of like 50 50. but
if you
you have if i told you that one of the
causes was actually activated
then that intuitively lessens
um the
responsibility and you don't really need
this other cause to explain a so that's
why the probability of this other
cause goes down
so of course that is very hand wavy but
you can rest assured that there is a
rigorous mathematical calculations
behind that that just did
okay so let's look at another
example this is kind of a toy medical
diagnosis problem so suppose you are
coughing and you have itchy eyes
you have a cold or
something else
so remember there's four steps so let's
go through them in turn so the first
step is to
write down what are the random variables
um of interest
so here we have cold
c allergies a cough
h and itchy eyes
i
okay so
um these are variables c a
h and i
so the second step is to draw arrows
between them using prior knowledge so
using a really super crude
medical knowledge i'm gonna just declare
that
well cough could be either because of
cold or allergies whereas heis is
generally due to allergies alone but not
cold
so step three is i'm going to make this
quantitative by defining local
conditional distribution so i'm going to
for each
variable
i'm going to write down a local
conditional distribution given its
parent so probability of c c has no
parents
probability of a a has no parents
um probability of h given its parent c
and a
and probability of i given its parent a
okay so i'm not going to bother to write
down the actual uh probability
distribution on the slide
um step four is to multiply all these
together
to form
the joint distribution
over all the random variables and
lowercase p is local conditional
distribution blackboard p is the joint
distribution
okay so now i can ask this i have this
probability database now we can ask
questions about it so
let's warm up um not exactly with this
question but a different question which
is what is the probability i have a cold
if i just were coughing
okay
so let's look at this demo
so here is
um
bayesian network for medical diagnosis
where i've defined
um c
a
um h
and i
and now i'm conditioning on h equals one
and i equals one
um and i'm asking for the probability of
c
marginalizing out a
okay so i am going to
there's a few times it runs the sum
variable animation algorithm which don't
worry about that for now
um and it produces that the probability
of c condition on equals one y equals
one is
point one three
um
sorry
this uh i meant to only condition on h
equals one
so let me do that again and i get
.28 so i'm gonna write point
here
and now what is the probability when i
condition on both um h equals one and i
equals one
and actually i already did this but i'll
just do it again
this is going to be 0.13
okay
so again you can rest assured that
these calculations were followed before
using laws of probability
and one thing i want to point out is
that this is another case of explaining
away but slightly disguised
so here's how to think about it so um i
condition
on i equals one so i observe that i have
heis okay so heis is only connected to a
so that's only going to boost
support for a
even though i don't condition on a i'm
getting more support for a
and now having more support for a
now this isn't explaining away
why
the cough so now a can explain the cough
which lessens the need for
the cold
so that's why the probability of cold
actually decreases compared to if i
didn't have hei
okay so you should be really kind of
impressed by this kind of
reasoning it's it's quite subtle even
for
this very small four node bayesian
network and even qualitatively you might
think
it's it's time hard to understand what
we'll happen to see
so just uh imagine if you have a huge
bayesian network and you want to get
qualitatively precise answers
um you should be glad that we have
vision networks that can allow you to
answer these questions
based on laws of probability
so
now let's define
bayesian networks formally so a bayesian
network
is specified by a set of random
variables generically x1 to xn
and it specifies a direct acyclic graph
over these random variables
so that specifies the
dependencies qualitatively
and then we specify a local conditional
distributions for each
variable x i given
the parents
of x i
and when you
multiply all these
local conditional distributions together
then you get
the joint distribution over all the
random variables
okay so again we're using local
uh
lowercase p to denote local conditional
distributions and blackboard p to denote
joint distribution
so now we can look at probabilistic
inference more formally as well so
all the same friends you're given as
input a bayesian network specifying this
joint distribution so this is my
probabilistic database
i get some evidence
where a subset of the variables e
has been observed to take on particular
values on little e
and i'm interested in a set of query
variables q which is another set of
variables
so now the probabilistic inference
produces
a probability of q
conditioned on the evidence
and
just to be very precise what this means
this is
a probability
u equals q given equals e
for each value
uh little q
for example
if i have
different coffee and have heis we have a
cold
this is expressed as this probabilistic
inference question what is the
probability of a cold condition on
coughing and hdrs
so this is a formal definition of
probabilistic inference
um the bad news is that answers
computing this is actually going to turn
out to be very computationally
intractable
but we'll see algorithms that can tackle
either approximately or special cases
surely
so in summary we've introduced bayesian
networks
it's important to think about
the basis of asian networks is based on
these random variables which capture the
state of the world
we have directed edges between these
variables which represent
directional dependencies
quantitatively we define a local
conditional distribution for each
variable it's conditioned on its parents
and we multiply all those together to
produce a joint distribution
now this joint distribution is my
probabilistic database where i can ask
questions about
the world
and this is the process of probabilistic
inference
and hopefully through the alarm and the
medical diagnosis examples
hopefully you can appreciate um the
framework which is bayesian networks and
that captures certain types of reasoning
patterns such as explaining away which
might be intuitive or counter-intuitive
but you can rest that well at night
because this is all based on laws of
probability okay